I do think that there may be a specific role.
You just heard about CILTA cell, 10% non-relapse mortality, significant, significant, rare,
but very serious leg complications, Parkinson's, the corticolitis, and the insurginal secondary
lymphomas.
So this is where currently CILTA cell is now in first line.
Ida cell is second line.
I don't think that, I mean, I'm going to ask, raise your hands, how many of you have actually
prescribed Ida cell in the last year?
Okay.
One, two.
No, there's two.
I think it's three.
Three.
Okay.
How many of you prescribed Ida cell more than once?
So there is use.
Okay.
It's out of the garage.
Yeah.
So at least the people from, the people from BMS might be happy.
I have to say, the last time I prescribed Ida cell was actually on the protocol we'll talk
about, and then maybe one patient specifically because there were a frail patient and we
were concerned about, frail patient with neuro, with neurocomorbidities, we, we, we are concerned
about neurotoxicity.
I don't have to, you know, we've already reviewed, you know, CILTA cell is obviously a much more
effective product, also much more toxic.
So why, what's the biggest difference?
Ida cell has one binding domain, CILTA cell has two, Ida cell has less CRS, I cell, and
I think, you know, the way it's constructed is probably the reason why CILTA cell is more
effective, but also more toxic.
Now, interestingly enough, and I remember Ida cell was the first to get there.
So the 2023 sales were similar.
I think this is actually changing.
So as part of this talk, I asked the question, where could Ida cell make?
A difference and Algarfa and I had the honor together with the BMT CTN to planning this study.
This was a phase two multi-center trial of anti-B cell maturation antigen.
This was Ida cell, we call it target CR.
And the main gist here was based on the study that we did, we knew that patients who did not
achieve a complete remission on lenalidomide maintenance had a high risk of relapsing over
the next two years.
So if you were MRD positive at the,
12-month mark after transplant on lenalidomide maintenance, your relapse risk was more than 20%
over the next 24 months.
So the idea was, can we convert somebody who had less than or equal VGPR into a CR or preferably
MRD negative CR with the use of Ida cell?
So the study actually required pain lengths to be on maintenance for at least three months to be
able to declare that they would not achieve a complete remission.
And then we would collect for Ida cell, we do the lymphodepleting.
Then chemo, and then we proceed to infusion of Ida cell.
And these are just basically the baseline.
We have very high response rates, more than 80% with very high MRD negative negativity rate to 10
to the minus five and some to 10 to the minus six.
And this is a swimmer's plot, which only, I think we had one patient who progressed before getting
the cells because they progressed during bridging and the other patient who progressed after
getting the cells, everybody else remains in a complete remission.
Everybody else remains without progression.
Most of them with MRD negative CRs, no late neurotoxicities, no late Parkinson's.
So if this is one area, and I do think that first question is, is converting an MRD positive PR or
VGPR to an MRD negative actually change overall outcomes?
I think that question needs to be answered in a randomized trial.
My grandchildren will be probably getting married by the time that study reads out, but I mean, it will be, it's an important study.
It needs to be done.
And this is, you know, well, what about Cilta?
So we'll be able to achieve the same thing.
The answer is yes.
But even in a trial, you know, credit to two, which was in a relatively similar group of patients, there still were deaths
from late toxicities, probably from infection.
So this is, again, this is from the stamina trial from primer, and it just shows you how that MRD positivity at the
one year mark in patients on lenalidomide maintenance actually predicts for something bad happening over the
next two years.
And it's not only progression.
I mean, this is a difference in overall survival.
So I do think that we are, and if you look at those Delta, I mean, it is a study that can reasonably be done.
And I think one of the products to explore is IDA cell in this setting.
So how can we make IDA cell better?
This is a study that we call the big bets and it's actually, it's very interesting.
So if we think about how many patients have cells in the freezer because they were collected during the first induction,
and when IDA cell was initially approved, it was approved in patients who had at least three lines of salvage therapy.
So the question comes up is how fit are the lymphocytes of a patient with myeloma,
who many of them had undergone an auto transplant, who've had three lines of salvage therapy.
What do those lymphocytes look like?
Could we actually make those lymphocytes fitter if we went on and gave the patients high dose melphalan,
use the cells that we had collected previously, wait three months until that patient had immunologic recovery,
collect those lymphocytes, which would be derived by stem cells that were in the freezer for all those years.
And we're probably much better than the stem cells that were in the patients getting all those lines of treatment.
And could that IDA cell or those CAR Ts be a better product?
And this is the, this is, this is Carlo Parica's work.
This is our preliminary data.
This should not be published yet.
So I'm going to, I didn't put, this should not be taken pictures of and they'll put it on Instagram, but there was a difference in,
in the CD4 and CD8 central memory cells.
So phenotypically, they're different.
It's interesting.
I thought the absolute lymphocyte counts were going to be different.
The answer is no.
The other thing in talking about reducing, these patients had a lot of disease when they were coming in.
High dose melphalan and auto transplant is a really good bridging therapy.
It gets people in remission and those remissions, even without anything usually last three to four months.
So when they were getting,
into their treatment for CAR-T, they were usually with low burden disease and it was much better tolerated.
So in conclusion, cilta cell is a better product than IDA cell in regards to efficacy.
And although more toxic, the current utilization suggests that IDA cell might be limited to frailer patients or patients with neurological
morbidities, IDA cell could find its niche in patients with standard risk, but suboptimal respondents, this will require large studies.
And with the advent of a needle cell, further use of IDA cell is likely to decrease.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.